why don't we go next to Jason from
Virginia Jason from Virginia welcome to
the program
hey David how's it going it's going well
hey uh just uh following up about that
uh tweet controversy how do you feel
about uh getting acknowledged by Donald
Trump Jr and potentially the Taliban
well listen here's something that's
fascinating Donald Trump Jr and the
Taliban were able to find Common Ground
they really didn't like my tweet about
gun safety
um now Don Jr didn't like it because he
falsely claims and whether he believes
it or not that I'm blaming the kids who
died for the shooting which of course
I'm not I'm blaming the politicians who
send thoughts prayers and do nothing
else the Taliban liked I'm sorry didn't
like what I said
but their context was that I'm just I
think they use the term Zionist which
for them just means Jew they took the
anti-semitic approach
so I mean listen politics I guess makes
strange bedfellows Don Jr and the
Taliban uniting against David Pacman it
is it's not the way I expected the week
to go I admit
I I couldn't believe it and then you
know reading just all the hateful
comments just uh you know but it made me
realize that what we see online isn't
relevant you know or representative of
the real world right in what sense but
just like uh you know uh the the online
audience is maybe more Amplified and you
know oh yeah maybe the general
population feels right and you know
what's funny is in the last few days
I've been out usually like when I go to
the grocery store one or two people
recognize me or if I'm in a restaurant
like one person will recognize me or
whatever it's like they all just come up
to me they have no idea about the
controversy like that you know it's like
every five seconds I'm getting a tweet
but out there it's sort of like most
normal people are just kind of Behaving
normally
I'm very good because some of the
comments were threatening in a way that
was concerning to me so hopefully of
course yeah and there's actually there's
a number of law enforcement
investigations already into those you
you might be shocked to hear
wow yeah all right well thank you so
much all right there's Jason from
Virginia great to hear from you